je place au questionnaire le
questionnaire dix questions
traditionnelles
le questionnaire le questionnaire
[Musique]
questionnaire fabrice pour terminer
baisser votre mot préféré et c'est
vraiment un seul - vous me limiter à un
mot total
non mais vous faites vite un bruit je
vais très très vite croquis les mots
coque coquelicot coquecigrues coquinerie
coquillettes pierre bergère votre mot
préféré eric emmanuel schmitt doute dû
en soi giroud pour sa sonorité kébé
reuze pour son sens temps presse autre
mot préféré jean luc godard schmouth le
mot juste
s'il vous plaît merci à savoir à mon
prénom
non aucun tant pis enfin concupiscent il
me vous disent rien mais c'est le mot
est composée notamment de mot ça je peux
pas vous le dire à la télévision
ah bon mais si c'est dû aussi si au
contraire ça vraiment je ne peux pas
pourquoi ma mère ma mère regardent
peut-être l'émission on en a je ne peux
pas votre mot préféré papa papa moi
c'est maman votre mot préféré donner
mitterrand n'atteindrait ce la douceur
dans votre mot préféré mais s'est dit
entre manger passion amour aimer tout
simple amitié quel est votre mot préféré
himal du bonheur bonheur michel mauran
votre mot préféré vie au commencement
votre mot préféré sur emmanuel ya là ce
qui veut dire en avant
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai dit comme ça j'ai
dit ah bon dieu demain tout commence
demain votre mot préféré à mettre vos
fesses métamorphose moments préférés je
crois que c'est armani alors votre mot
préféré lumière lumière marcello lumière
ça contient à la paix l'amour dieu puis
c'est la chose qu'on voit qu'on a à la
naissance et qu'on a la mort
et puis à lumière c'est le cinéma les
frères lumière
[Musique]